this is an independent virologist and
vaccine expert
uh who's also what his uh his
credentials include he's formerly
employed at
uh gaffy i don't know what gabby is the
bill and the bill and melinda gates
foundation
so these are we've got three papers
um all of which he he's he's just
written and posted on his uh linkedin
page
and he's also got a few uh youtube
interviews out now
and um and he is basically trying to
raise the alarm
about the risk of mass vaccination
of the sort of vaccines that we've got
now um
during a pandemic being he is arguing
likely to actually cause ancova 19 to
become a much worse problem than it
already is and in fact become
uh a global nightmare um the likes of
which we've never seen
that's that's his statement that's it
that's his position and he knows he does
say
i think he alludes to the fact that he
has a manuscript that covers this
that he is putting through proper
channels but he says we don't have time
which is why i'm posting it in this way
and um so
we really uh just you know truth truth
in advertising here
um a friend of mine sent me one of these
papers a couple days ago actually on my
patreon
uh and said can you please can you tell
me what to think of this
and i spent a little bit of time with it
and i will say that one of these three
papers the one that i was sent first the
one dated so there's a march
13th of march 17th and a march 6th and
the march 6th one and i'll post these
all
um on on the show notes as well
the march 6th one is is weird it's tough
to get through and it makes a bunch of
claims that seem
bizarre and i could i it was it was hard
to
hard to parse but the later papers and
you know we're still talking about just
within a few days
of now um are very much more clear
and he's also given a ton of references
which i have not had time to look
through the vast majority of them yet
but the basic the basic framework is
we are not thinking about this
evolutionarily and
the the refusal to do so
risks a whole lot of humanity and you
know that as
a is a is a base claim
is a perfect match for what we've been
saying from the beginning
that we that we need to think about what
this virus will do
how it will change understanding
therefore its origins
affects what we can imagine it will be
able to do
quickly if it came directly from either
a primary secondary host or if it
experienced
gain of function research and serial
passaging in a lab and therefore
is already sort of pre-adapted as of a
year plus ago
to human hosts um these are not merely
academic questions they actually
potentially affect human health and
and and he brings that into the vaccine
framework specifically
yeah i will say i found these um papers
challenging and there were a couple
places where i wondered if we were
tripping over a language issue where he
used um he used terms that i think
actually aren't the right terms but that
there was an argument so
i i will say i don't find anything
i don't find that this is like the judy
mikovich
situation where there were claims that
were made
that were simple enough to falsify that
it's just
red flags all over the place yep in this
case i don't have that or those two
doctors out of current county
early you know last last spring um who
were making a lot of claims that just
were easily
falsifiable yep um this this is not that
this is not bad
and so at the basic level and i think
your summary is right the basic argument
here so there
are specific arguments which i'll try to
make clearer in a second but the basic
argument that we are not thinking
evolutionarily about what we're doing
and we are
blindly stumbling into this landscape we
are intervening in a way that could make
things worse
and not better is accurate
and i definitely think you know we are
long overdue to be having an
evolutionary conversation about
this virus and our approach to it
interestingly
i do not find in what i've read here
an analog for the argument that you and
i have made
that we are that these vaccines are so
narrowly targeted
that instead of using a complete virus
by using the spike protein as
a single target that that these these
vaccines are very
narrowly focused and that that is going
to create a concentrated evolutionary
um pressure so yeah gosh i thought i had
seen that in here somewhere but i don't
i don't see it now
um but and but so that's that's a
particular argument that we have made
so he makes analogous argument yes so my
think my
thinking is either it's in here and i
don't see it um or
it's not in here and it belongs in the
same discussion
there's a whole category of
possibilities that deserve to have
consideration and it feels like he's got
a few possibilities and they're not
always totally teased apart carefully
but he's proposing a few things right
yeah he's proposing for instance that
mass vaccination during a time of
pandemic
puts puts humanity at risk because
if you if you vaccinate when there's not
when you are
when those who are recently vaccinated
tell me if you think i've got this right
if you vaccinate if you get vaccinated
when you are unlikely to run
into the wild type pathogen out there in
the world
your body will have time to create
immunity to it when you do run into it
but during a pandemic you are likely to
run into the thing that you've just been
vaccinated against
before you actually have immunity to it
and
this may basically produce
a inability for the virus
to uh to adapt and become
immune itself to adapt away from the
vaccine
it's not that you don't have immunity to
it because presumably whatever level of
immunity you don't have you have before
the vaccination his point is that
there is a stage after you have been
vaccinated
the first time and before you have been
vaccinated the second time and had the
period in which for your immune system
to become specifically targeted
that you are effectively um weakly
immune and that weak immunity therefore
selects for the invisibility of the
virus to the vaccine
and so this is in many ways analogous to
the thing that you and i are talking
about
which is the narrow focus of our
vaccines now it may be that they can
only be narrowly focused it may be that
there's nothing else
in this virus that actually is
accessible to
uh the immune system and therefore it
may be that there's
you know that there's no consequence to
to what you and i have worried about but
i'd like to know that that's
true rather than just it's something we
assume yeah
um but so he seems to be making two
points
one is that the partial immunity
that um people get from this
vaccine on the way to being immunized
assuming they're effective right is an
evolutionary pressure
that these vaccines do not appear to
be good at preventing people from
transmitting viruses that they've
already been infected with
i'd like to know if that's the case i
know that this has been suspected this
has been suspected but yeah i saw that
claim here too and there's no reference
like i don't i don't know this to be
true right but let's say
it is true his point is that what we are
effectively doing is
creating what is
to un unfortunately is the same word i
just used in effect
like running a gain of function
experiment
with humanity by creating a concentrated
evolutionary
pressure for the invisibility and
he imagines that very disastrous things
could be the result of this which i
don't think are certain
but are plausible as far as i can tell
so i i agree
um he also argues um and i
again i think you may be able to add
clarity to this because i wasn't sure
exactly what his argument was he argued
something like
given that older people given that
covid absent the regime of vaccination
has affected older people more and more
seriously as everyone on the planet
knows at this point
therefore older people are being
vaccinated first
which would appear to be the appropriate
move
um but that leaves a situation in which
the way that the viru
another way that the virus may evolve in
response to this if there is a
basically and i'm adding this here but
especially if there's a slow if you know
if the goal is to get everyone
vaccinated if there's a slow
roll out and um
then and the virus can't get purchased
on increasing numbers of of the older
population that is going to evolve
precisely to become more likely to
infect
younger people and he argues i believe
in one of these papers that because we
also have at the same time
children who have been pretty isolated
for a long time and
who are now about to go back into
schools um that this may create uh sort
of a perfect petri dish situation
well i don't let me let me let me try to
buy this let me clarify his argument
just so we know at least not we're
talking about okay so he makes
um two arguments the first one
related to what we've already talked
about is that our behavior
deploying what he says are prophylactic
vaccines
in the midst of a pandemic so his his
point
is and he makes very clear he's not an
anti-vaxxer he's very pro-vaxxed
but his point is look if you were to
deploy these vaccines in advance
of a pathogen arriving somewhere it
might be very
effective at ratcheting up the immune
response so that the virus would not
get a purchase on the population if you
do it in the context of a pandemic
already in motion
his point is what you're doing is you
are confronting a virus which has the
capacity to evolve
with a concentrated selection pressure
with a selection pressure and his point
is it cannot help but push this virus
into uh an arms race which i think is
right and is consistent with what you
and i have said
um and that that arms race is very
likely to have these other consequences
which is where this point about young
people versus old people comes up just
one point of order though you said
that he says and i see it in the papers
too he calls it prophylactic vaccine
i that seems redundant to me vaccines
are inherently prophylactic prophylaxis
being about prevention
right rather than retreating of symptoms
it's an individual versus population
level question when he says
a prophylactic vaccine he's talking
about the population level
um and for an individual yes it's
prophylactic either way
so you think that his argument there is
that the vaccine itself is designed
to be prophylactic at a population level
and it is being used in a situation
where the population has already been so
widely exposed and continues to be
exposed
that it is not being deployed in a way
that is consistent with prophylaxis
right
so and there is a very powerful
evolutionary argument here which
is it is the arms race that creates the
ferocious enemy
right and so you do not want to
invite an arms race you cannot win and
in this case the point is we're making
this move
because we don't have another right and
so we're making a move that we shouldn't
make because what it's going to do is
turn our enemy much more dangerous than
it is
and i'm not saying that that's true i
think there are ways in which this could
be false but it is not obvious to me
that it is false
right and i in fact the arms race part
of it is almost certain to be true
so the second part of the argument and
there is one part of this
that may be well known but i don't know
it and so i i'm
cautious about it but his point is that
actually by keeping
young people um away from
each other and society that we are
weakening their
what's called innate immunity so and
he deploys a model that i think is is
quite valuable the way
he puts it basically that we start out
with
innate immunity that is to say an immune
system in our lives in our lives
neonates
right that doesn't have to um
generate novel insight so when we get
sick with something like the flu we've
never seen it before it gets past our
defenses and then we build
an immunity to it and then we build a
memory of that immunity right
so that is adaptive immunity and it's
actually one of the most marvelous
evolutionary stories there is it's an
evolution that takes place in your
lifetime
inside your body between your cells so
young people have the innate immunity
but it is not programmed with the
adaptive component which result which
results from encounters with things in
the world
we expect our adaptive humanity to get
better over time right
and so the model he deploys is
over time as you as you age your
innate immunity weakens you get more
vulnerable but your
adaptive immunity grows better because
it has seen the things in your
environment for the most part
it becomes wise right it becomes wise
exactly and so
the point is older people are feeble
with respect to their ability to keep
stuff out but they're better with
respect to being able to fight stuff
that their immune system is aware of
um now the part of this that i think is
insecure and it may be that it is well
known the part of his argument that you
think is insecure
i mean my understanding it's right there
to the left of the
oh yeah my understanding of this is all
kind of old because
uh came from a course that involved that
textbook but
um in any case the the
argument he he makes is that
the innate immunity and he uses a bad
analogy but if we can correct it
i think what he means to say is that the
innate immunity is in some sense like a
muscle
that to the extent that your innate
immunity is not
encountering things in the wild it
stands down it atrophies
and so by isolating young people
that we would be reducing their capacity
to fend off
you know why are young people immune to
this it's not because their
immune systems are aware of covid it's
because their immune systems are good at
generally dealing with stuff
and preventing it from getting in your
cells they don't have adaptive immunity
they do have very strong innate immunity
this does raise the question of why so
many pathogens are so much
more likely to to attack young people
but
um to generalize further what you're
saying by analogy to muscles is what he
is saying
um the argument is that innate immunity
is anti-fragile
right that it becomes it becomes better
with insult it becomes better with
pressures against it
right and so anyway i want to know
there's there's and the problem is there
are two arguments that overlap so
um george carlin had a very famous
routine in which he argued that
uh he didn't get sick because he had
swam in the hudson and you know
um right but anyway so the the police
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
argument right right and the point is we
know that this
will have some some reality over an
adaptive immunity space that in effect
the challenges cause your immunity to
learn about things in the environment
the argument that it's happening on the
innate immunity may be true but i want
to see
the evidence that it is yeah this was
exactly one of the places
i hung up too like i don't i don't know
about this claim
and but but anyway the consequence of
all of this
is his point is we are creating a
what he is arguing is effectively a
perfect storm in which we are
setting up an arms race with the virus
where the virus will
mutate away into invisibility to the
immune system so we will
educate the immune system basically like
putting up a wanted poster
in the post office that alerts the
immune system to who it's looking for
the enemy will disguise itself and be
able to uh to move
in without uh being spotted and that
that
will then result in it
honing in on young people who have not
uh been exposed and are therefore
vulnerable
and basically they would be a reservoir
of
potential potential victims of the virus
and that this could create
a catastrophe so
i think where i come out on this is
this argument definitely needs to be
heard what i don't want and what we are
forced to effectively by the way
that we are dealing with um this
pandemic
is i don't want either people with
perverse incentives
to tell us why this isn't true right
what i want is people who are
immune to pressure right and
aware of various different relevant
aspects of this
to be able to have a conversation in
which they determine
because effectively what he's arguing is
that we should pull these vaccines
right that we are in fact going to
destroy herd immunity which would grow
right grow with huge costs right we are
going to destroy the herd immunity that
we've already
inadvertently invested so heavily in and
create effectively a novel and much
worse
much more effective pandemic now
that is a plausible argument is it a
true argument
um i can see ways in which it could be i
can also see reasons that it might not
be
yet but the discussion is where you
would find that out you need people
who are sophisticated about the
evolutionary stuff to have
you know a candid conversation with each
other about what would the effect
of this be if x y or z
and i have very little doubt we're not
going to get that discussion
yeah no i i agree so i uh
boy i don't know where that leaves us um
i think uh you know i'm
i'm glad that this that he's out there
saying what he's saying and i would like
the conversations between people who are
interested in truth
and who do not have perverse incentives
to be happening
and um instead there's
it just seems like there's a rapid fire
exchange of
is this true is this true this is true
and no it couldn't be because
it doesn't suit my worldview responses
well i would say i see that but i also
think that you know
the most frustrating aspect is
why are people dealing with this as if
they are not intervening in a complex
system
right this is something that you and i
have been saying consistently which is
you're dealing with the most complex of
complex systems you're talking about
intervening in immunity where you have
you know evolutionary phenomenon on the
part of the immune system
evolutionary phenomena on the part of uh
the viruses and interactions so
you know one of the things i don't think
he does say anywhere in
what i've seen is where is the
invisibility
for this virus right to the extent that
we create pressure
to not look like what we already know it
looks like and that causes variants to
emerge that are
more or less invisible to the immune
system well
that can be a permanent arms race we can
keep chasing the virus and
keep reinforming the immune system and
that is likely to have costs i don't
know what they are
or it could be that the immune says that
the
virus finds a hole in the immune system
and the holes in the immune system
people who have watched our live streams
before will remember discussions
of self versus non-self recognition
that our system basically recognizes
anything organic that doesn't match
molecules we ourselves produce
right that's an amazing magic trick of
uh development
that basically is the basis of the the
adaptive immune response
however because our systems have to not
respond to self
right in order for this magic trick to
work that means that to the extent that
we
push a virus into looking more like us
at a molecular level
it becomes invisible in a way that we
can't chase it and so
what role this has to play in something
like autoimmunity if a virus
becomes molecularly similar enough to
something that you
create yourself that the immune system
can't see it then the immune system
either pursues it and attacks your
tissues or doesn't pursue it and it
escapes and so anyway
you're sick one way or the other right
and so the question you know we've been
talking about autoimmunity as one of the
things
that it ought to be on people's radar
you know
cancer ought to be on people's radar
autoimmunity ought to be on people's
radar these are general failure modes
that arise from the fact that this
complex system
is predicated on certain kinds of
assumptions and if you push one way
you're going to end up here you're going
to end up there or you're going to end
up there you know
you've got autoimmunity you've got
cancer you've got destruction of tissue
and aging
right these are all failure modes and
we're pushing on them as if
you know we know what we're doing and
the fact is no it's very early in
the discovery of all of the biological
phenomena in question we're not experts